okay so opening our file in the browser
is probably not what you expected
looking at it in developer tools the
structure is exactly as you defined it
but the style description isn't there
and the browser uses its default style
for all of the elements and as you can
see it's not very pretty and the visual
layout is completely off as well let's
go ahead and add in some styles do you
remember earlier when I talked about the
HTML file telling the browser where to
find the style information yeah we need
to add that first you need to add a
single line at the start of the HTML
file this tells the browser that the
type of document is an HTML document
then you need to add the top-level tag
HTML because everything here is HTML and
don't forget every time we have the
start tag we also need to have the end
tag and then so our code is easier to
read will indent our HTML structure so
that it's located in between our two
HTML tags after the HTML tag we need to
add a head tag this is where you'll add
the link to the style file to add a link
to the style file we start typing link
and then hit tab here sublime text has
automatically filled in all of the
information we need except for the name
of the file that contains our style
information which in this case is called
style dot CSS after the closure of the
head tag we then add the body tag now
contained within our body tags will be
our HTML structure that we wrote before
so we need to move this code in between
our body tags again for code readability
we've indented the HTML structure so
that we have a bit more to look and work
with let's replace the placeholder
description with some text you can
choose to write your own text or simply
use what we've provided in the
instructor notes once the text is added
save the file and then refresh your
browser page you can see that it updated
with the text that we've included and
since
you've linked your stylesheet to your
HTML file you can go to the style dot
CSS file and add some style to the page
and just for fun how about we add the
following style save the file and
refresh your browser then tell me what
happened did the box with class
description turn red did all text turn
red or did the text in the description
box turn red or did nothing happen